دبدوب احمر وشوكولاته شاب يطالب خطيبته
برد الهدايا والاموال بعد فسخ الخطوبه
[موسيقى]
صوره لورقه مطبوعه اثارت الكثير من الضجه
على مواقع التواصل الورقه تتضمن كشفا
لهدايا ومصاريف تتكبدها الشاب اثناء خطبته
[موسيقى]
لكن الخطوبه فاشله وتم الانفصال التفاصيل
في الورقه لافته مثلا تتحدث عن مصاريف
حفله الخطوبه وهي اربعه الاف جنيه وتتحدث
ايضا عن حفل عيد ميلاد بكلفه 1500 جنيه
واكثر من ذلك يذكر الشاب في قائمه كلفه
هدايا عيد الحب ومنها الشوكولاته ومنها
ايضا دبدوب احمر وسعره بحسب القائمه 250
جنيه ويذكر الشاب في قائمته انه لم يحسب
كل شيء كمصاريف المطاعم والفسح والمواصلات
[موسيقى]
ويذكر ان الخطيبه كانت تتناول طعام الغداء
على حسابه لان والدتها متوفى
هذا التصرف هل هو من حق الخطيب الحزين ام
هو تجاوز لكل الاعراف شاركونا رايكم
[موسيقى]